So there are days when I'll be checking out some awesome Android app, when I run into an
anti-pattern that's pure anti-Android and which
totally destroys the magic, and I'm all like:
Well, my team are sick of me making a mess of their workspace, so I'm channeling my energy
into something more productive. Welcome:
To Tableflip.
Today I'm returning to the topic of one of my earliest Android UX rants:
"exit" menu items.
Back in the days before time began when humans typed into terminal prompts
while huddled in dark caves, Googling Wikipedia for fire;
single-tasking operating systems like MS-DOS allowed us to run one app at a time.
"Exit" was unambiguous. A necessity for leaving one app and starting another.
The instruction itself had semantic meaning.
"Exit" mapped to the C function Exit(), which terminated the calling process.
As we crawled from our hidden caves hunting the last of the Woolly Mammoth
multi-tasking operating systems like Windows enabled us to run multiple
programs at once
each represented by its own window.
As before, our exit menu-item is used to call exit(), to terminate the process, and
allow us to reclaim the resources used by the task window.
Having grown fat and complacent within multi-tasking Operating Systems gorging
on a glut of RAM and CPU resources provided by Moore's Law, smartphones
introduced a new challenge.
How do we create a responsive multi-tasking operating system with a fraction of the
resources?
Unlike windowed operating systems, smart phones generally present apps full-screen
and one at a time -- so it's easy to establish a relative priority
between applications
following Android's Three Laws of Robotics.
One. Whichever App is in the foreground
must have the resources it needs to run
and run responsively.
Two. Any application with a visible activity
or a running Service, should be allowed to run, except when doing so would be in
violation of the first law.
And three.
Any application without a visible Activity or a running service should be kept in
memory to reduce startup latency
except when doing so would be in violation of the first and second
laws.
Much as Asimov's three laws were build into all positronic brains
so to have Android's laws been baked into the platform.
This has three implications for app design.
Firstly, knowing the OS can terminate your app's process without
warning at any time
you can't rely on having an onExit() handler that will be called when your app is
closed.
Instead, your Activities should listen for
onPause handlers that
indicate your app is no longer active.
At this point is may be terminated at any time, so it should save any user
data to prevent potential data loss.
When your Activity is no longer visible
it'll receive an onStop handler.
A good app will treat this handler as the equivalent of an onExit() handler, reducing its
resource usage as much as possible.
We already know that background apps are low priority, so they should consume the
absolute minimum in terms of resources
even without the system having to
terminate them.
Doing so will increase the chances of your app remaining running, thereby
decreasing startup time and improving responsiveness.
So thanks to the three laws, your app doesn't need an exit button, but what's the harm
in having one anyway?
Why do these seemingly insignificant UI elements fill me with a dark and fire-ey
rage that burns as intensely as the heart of a neutron star?
Where does that anger go?
Well, I bottle up my emotions into a dark fist of psychic hate that I can
harness and unleash on unwary foes.
And an "Exit" Menu Item in Android has no system-wide
semantic meaning.
so including one in your app introduces ambiguity.
Consider the Google apps that typically ship with most Android devices. Imagine if Gmail
gallery, or the Contacts apps had exit buttons.
What would you expect them to do?
Chances are you've never looked for an exit button in these apps, and have never been
disappointed that it's not there.
If you build an application that properly
handles its state transitions: Is predictable, configurable, and
unambiguous
your users won't ask for an exit button.
But what about apps like Music, Navigation, and Banking -- whose background behavior
demand stronger user messages?
For them we need an explicit exit button, but fortunately that's exactly what the "back"
button does on Android.
When a user presses "Back"
the Activity calls finish() -- explicitly destroying the Activity and freeing its
resources, making it a functional equivalent to the exit() button in days of
yore.
For most apps, it makes little difference if the user is exiting explicitly or
switching to another app
but in some cases this additional signal can be useful.
Apps like a movie or music players don't need this signal as they already show their
users semantic controls to determine ongoing behavior.
A music player, for example, should keep rocking out until you pause playback.
Turn-by-turn navigation though, has no simple cues.
In this rare example it can be useful to interpret a back button press as an
explicit request to "end all route guidance".
Some apps -- such as instant messaging, banking, or remote terminal sessions
may need a way to terminate the current session.
whether it be for security or resources
usage reasons
Rather than using the semantically ambiguous "exit" menu item,
it's better practice to include a menu item that describes exactly what will
happen
such as "logout" / "signout" or similar descriptive actions.
For users who want to take the proverbial shotgun to the head of zombie background
apps
they can force stop a process from the apps setting
as well as swiping to remove apps from the application switcher on newer Android
platform releases.
I'm nearly done, but I can already hear the fevered tapping of fingers on keyboards
as some of you prepare your own retaliatory rants, railing against the
arrogance
at the presumption of knowing
what uses want better than themselves.
I know, from having been told, that yes
many app developers will still receive requests to add an exit button to their apps
generally so users can unambiguously prevent the app from consuming any further
resources.
I understand the perspective, but expecting that the developer of an app
which doesn't properly manage its resources
to manage them correctly simply by adding an "exit" menu item
introduces a certain level of cognitive
dissonance.
If a developer can't manage their resources effectively without an exit button
at reason do you have to believe they will handle their resources more
effectively
just because they include one?
If your users are still asking for an exit button, it's generally because they
believe your app is consuming resources when it shouldn't be.
Adding an exit button may give them a temporary feeling of hope
but it will quickly be extinguished in the swamp of tears and recrimination when the
ambiguity of their new exit option becomes apparent.
What should happen to Services when a user hits exit? What about Intent
Receivers? Widgets? Should you stop listening for GCM messages?
Different users will have difference expectations and satisfying some will
frustrate others.
The best solution is to obviate their perceived need for an exit button
by following these simple steps.
Start by freeing resources, stopping services, disabling sensor listeners and
turning off location requests, and otherwise disabling anything that consumes resources.
all within the onPause handler of your Activities.
Take this a step further by avoiding singletons and custom Application
objects within your application whenever possible.
If your resources are tied to your Activity
they'll be freed if the user hits the back button
rather than having to wait until the application process is terminated.
Another culprit for resource consumption is an app that sets alarms
to wake the device and poll for updates on a regular basis.
You can improve your apps battery-drain profile by making these alarms inexact
and allowing the user to specify the frequency of background updates.
But every time you ping your server when there was nothing to update you're not only
draining the battery from the device being on, you're also draining battery
by turning on the cell radio for no good reason.
Google Cloud Messaging lets you eliminate polling so you
only ping your server when you you have information
worth downloading
If your app does require
a way of "signing out" or "logging off" create an explicit
semantically meaningful, way of doing so rather than relying on an ambiguous
legacy "exit" command.
Music apps are the most common example of an app that should continue running at a high
priority
even when there is no activity visible.
However, when no music is playing, the app is no different to any other
background app.
When it is playing, make sure it's easy to stop.
Rich notifications and widgets should provide easy shortcuts to stop playback
at which point you should free resources in the same way as typical apps
within their onPause handlers.
Finally, the Android OS provides a number of cues of significant system
events -- including low battery and low memory.
Listen for these intents and modify the resource use profile
of your app accordingly.
Users only ask you to include an exit button if they blame your app for consuming memory
draining the battery, or otherwise deteriorating their overall experience.
Rather than implementing a menu item that won't solve their underlying problem
spend your time making your app more efficient.
My name is Reto Meier
and this was Table Flip.